[Musique]
oui la parole au total six messam alain
dupuis alors cette semaine j'ai envie de
continuer un peu l'écho à la journée du
8 mars la journée des droits de la femme
parce que les enjeux qui concernent des
femmes sont tellement grand et tellement
encore omniprésent ici au québec et au
canada que il faut continuer d'en parler
je m'excite la commission d' enquête sur
les femmes assassinées et disparues
auraient dû amener une plus grande
attention plus grande réponse justement
face aux situations qu'ils ont vécues
par les femmes autochtones au québec et
au canada
cependant je pense qu'en réponse aussi
avec la réaction pige en u ou à la
commission d enquête sur vérité et
réconciliation des fois certains de ces
enjeux le sont tellement larges vraiment
un grand touche tellement des différents
niveaux aussi de politiques
d'institutions que les gens des fois ça
leur passe au dessus de la paye puisque
c'est quand même réapprendre tout un pan
d'histoire c'est quand même resituer des
situations particulières liées aux
femmes autochtones
c'est un devoir de sociologie de puisque
je j d'histoire donc certains des enjeux
sont encore fini aurait zappé les enjeux
même sont diminués ou aux yeux du grand
public et je m'explique il ya beaucoup
d'enjeux présentant par exemple avec le
co vide comme madame carolyn bennett
déclaré cette semaine les femmes de
tonnes sont encore victimes de même
souvent les plus à risque pendant la
période du creux vide face aux violences
conjugales l'augmentation dès violences
conjugales est assez clair due aux
politiques de confinement l'on doit être
ensemble dans des maisons et donc
accéder dès fois à nos ressources
sécuritaire c'est plus difficile qu'on
peut pas aller rejoindre des gens qui
étaient nous nos systèmes de sécurité
habituelles donc c'est la même chose
pour toutes les femmes cependant chez
les femmes autochtones s'est aussi
amplifié par le fait que justement qu'on
est des grandes familles quand on est en
milieu urbain par exemple nous réseaux
sont pas les mêmes
comme sur une communauté le fait de ne
pas pouvoir aller visiter les gens s
offrir un répit aussi qui peut enlever
une tension dans les familles où qu'ils
peuvent créer même des des réseaux qui
vont prendre soin ou surveiller les
femmes vont disparaître donc il faut pas
non plus négliger le fait que dans les
milieux éloignés comme les communautés
très éloignés il n'y a pas d'accès à des
foyers de femmes par exemple dans
certaines communautés donc ça ça diminue
les chances que les femmes ont de
pouvoir sortir de ces situations là et
même de pouvoir mini-site service qui
serait peut-être plus accessible pour
des femmes allochtone il ya d'autres
enjeux aussi qui se vante en tant que
femme en période de coved et je pense à
beaucoup de femmes qui reçoivent des
notifications d'éviction parce que
soient ses dissimulé à travers une
reprise de loyer pour la famille de la
personne va dire c'est pour ma famille
où c'est pour moi que je reprends le
loyer parce que soient elles ces femmes
là on trop d'enfants sont tes enfants le
sont à la maison sont plus bruyants sont
plus présents de façon permanente donc
devient une nuisance et pour les
personnes qui sont tous mais ne devrait
pas avoir à se faire il va essayer de
leur logement ce qui est illégal et il
ne devrait pas avoir à se faire déloger
de peut-être d'andreu qui sont
pisciculteurs pour être obligé d'aller
vers des ressources qui des fois le sont
moins donc ça c'est des situations dans
lesquelles j'ai vu pendant le coc vide
qui touchent directement les femmes
autochtones d'autres enjeux qui ne sont
pas nécessairement liés uniquement avec
le co vide c'est aussi le fait que les
femmes autochtones vont avoir moins la
confiance envers les services policiers
par exemple trompe loire déclaré les
situations de violence conjugale et là
je prendrai des situations dans l'ouest
ou en colombie britannique où justement
avec la grc par exemple des
problématiques énorme de confiance
envers des services policiers on pense à
val-d'or aussi la situation des femmes
de val d'or les l'importance d'avoir un
sentiment de sécurité qu'on se tourne
vers des services policiers ou même les
services de santé
j'ai entendu d'autres situations où j'ai
même une moi même des réactions
par rapport aux vaccins par exemple ce
que vont nous donner le bon vaccin et le
travail énorme qui doit être fait par
les devants par exemple qui nous
rassemble justement sur le fait d'avoir
le même genre de qualité de vaccins que
le reste de la population
ça ne devrait pas exister mais c'est des
situations qui ont été mis en place
quand même par rapport aux structures et
aux systèmes qui a été placée autour des
communautés autochtones qui était
souvent malheureusement en train de
discrimination et de racisme
et là j'arrive sur d'autres niveaux qui
ne sont pas du niveau liés directement
aux corvées d'oublier du règlement
uniquement à la situation du club et des
services que les femmes peuvent
rejoindre mais c'est aussi les
situations politiques sociales qui
continue malgré le coc vide malgré le
confinement je donne un exemple le
reportage qui était sorti pour parler
des enjeux qui pouvait être très
difficile entre le leadership
traditionnel des chefs et le leadership
des femmes par exemple dans les centres
d'amitié autochtones comme quoi il y
avait des fois des problématiques de
dclear justement entre en respect des
rôles des femmes qui n'étaient pas dans
les réserves qui était dans les milieux
urbains et certaine de cette dynamique
existe et est plus complexe
mais pourquoi est ce que je dis que
c'est une problématique c'est que quand
on va aller en parler en politique
québécoise
en europe le problème à faire des
déclarations à faire une sortie par
exemple d'un organisme vert des chefs
vers des benzema déchets vers des
ministres
vendez des représentants politiques
traditionnelles du québec parce que ça
va c'est une manière de s'exprimer sur
la place publique et quand même
normalisé pour les femmes au québec
cependant ton était une femme autochtone
il faut pas négliger que c'est un aspect
qui touche non seulement les femmes
autochtones et beaucoup de gens qui sont
bien deux groupes racisés est-ce qu'on
va risquer d'exposer nos leaders nous
communauté en tant qu'autochtones sur
une place publique qui n'est pas
nécessairement tokten au sécuritaire est
exposée justement à défendre de de
discriminations de racisme de gêner
réalisation je vous donne un exemple
quand on ne parlait au début d'année au
moment de certains chefs qui avaient des
salaires extravagants
je me rappelle qu'il y avait une
généralisation complète sur leur chipe
des chefs de
les conseils de bande et donc c'était
même pas des individus comme on pourrait
faire ici au québec on prend 1,1 un élu
et on va observer sa manière de faire
c'est qu'on va faire une généralisation
sur les chefs autochtones en faire une
généralisation sur les pratiques des
femmes autochtones et là on va faire des
sorties publiques
en dix ans les autochtones sont comme si
les autochtones sont comme ça alors
qu'on ne regarde pas l'individu dont
combler d'autres volets parus alors
certaines des femmes qui veulent faire
des sorties publiques n'est pas parce
que justement le traitement de leurs
leaders vont être dans des fonds de
généralisation alors qu'on voudrait
régler des situations spécifiques avec
des individus spécifiques et ça demande
beaucoup de courage de pouvoir faire ça
et de le faire d'une manière qui
respectueuse et qui nous permet nous de
nous exprimer sans que justement
l'ensemble de la communauté soit ensuite
mis dans un espèce de grand groupes
étaient justement après même des
reproches aux fêtes auprès des femmes
qui ont osé parler ou s'élever condé
situation injuste
alors vous comprendrez que ce sont des
enjeux qui vont venir au cours des
prochaines années ce sont des
discussions qui va y avoir pu avoir lieu
mais cependant c'est important de les
avoir parce que cela va bénéficier les
femmes parce que justement ça va
permettre de clarifier des situations ou
même de changer des situations qui sont
injustes auprès de nos communautés
alors n'hésitez pas à partager cette
vidéo n'était pas envoyer des questions
et surtout n'oublie pas que maintenant
par la technique aussi disponible en
formant de podcasts donc trouver les
auprès de vos ressources de podcasts
préférées je souhaite une belle semaine